الى الاردن
في عدد من المدن الاردنيه بتزامن مع
الاضراب الذي نفذه سائق الشاحنات وعاملون
في قطاع النقل والشحن احتجاجا على رفع
اسعار المحروقات
وتجددت اعمال شغب في مدينه الكرك
والحسينيه واغلقت المحال التجاريه لليوم
الثاني على التوالي في مدينتين معنا
والكرك كما شهدت احياء في العاصمه عمان
وقفات تضامنيه مع المضربين رغم العوده
النسبيه لحركه الشحن في البلاد
السفاره الامريكيه في الاردن رعاياها من
السفر الشخصيه والرسميه الى مدن جنوب
البلاد وخاصه اذن الكرك والطفيله ومعان
والعقبه حتى اشعار جديد
وقال جهاز الامني الاردنيه النا ضابطا
برتبه عقيد قتل كما اصيب ضابط اخر وضابط
صف بعيارات ناريه اطلقها من وصفهم
بالمخرجين في مدينه الحسينيه بمحافظه
معانا اثرا دلاع ما قال انها اعمال شغب في
مدن الكرك والحسينيه ومدن اخرى جنوبي
البلاد احتجاجا على رفع اسعار المحروقات
وقال البيان من العقيد عبد الرزاق عبد
الحافظ الدلابيح قتل بعيار النبي
كل من يحاول الاعتداء على الارواح
والممتلكات العامه كما شدد البيان ان الام
ناس يتعامل وفق القانون باستخدام القوه
المناسبه مع كل من يقوم باعمال التخريب
ويحاول استغلال الظرف للماسيسي بحياه
المواطنين وترويحه
المزيد معنا من عمان مدير ومكتب الجزيره
حسن الشوبكي حسن اهلا بك اذا ضعنا في
الصوره واخر المستجدات في هذا الملف
يعني اخر المستجدات
سفيان كانت تعزيزات الامنيه التي ارسلها
الامن العام وقوات الدرك الى المناطق التي
تشد هذه المواجهات وفي مقدمتها
عدد من المدن الجنوبيه تحديدا في الكرك
وكذلك في منطقه الحسينيه
بمحافظه معان التي تبعد نحو 200 كيلو متر
عن العاصمه عمان هذا همم من جانب من جانب
اخر هنالك سيطره للامن على همم بعض اعمال
التي تحدث منذ ليله الماضيه
يعني همم الاهم جاء في بيان الامن العام
الاخير وهو ان هناك ضابط ضابط قد اصيب به
في المواجهات التي جرت في منطقه الحسينيه
وتم اسعافهما الى المستشفى وهما قيد
العلاج الان وقال همم في همم هذا السياق
ان هنالك من يعني هنالك جهات تحرض وتؤجج
الشارع وطالبه بالحذر في التعامل مع هذه
الامور يعني شارحا هذا الامر من خلال
القول بان همم الاعمال التخريبيه مجرمه
وان ما يفعلها سيكون تحت يعني طائله
القانون المحاسبه والملاحقه
وحضر ايضا من ان هناك من يبث معلومات
واخبار ملفقه وقال ان هناك من يسعى الى
تاجيل الشارع في كل الاحوال سفيان المشهد
همم يعني همم
كانت ليله صعبه على الامن وعلى الاردنيين
جميعا
يعني كان هنالك ايضا بيان خرج من ابناء
ووجاء همم مدينه معان السنكروا في همم
يعني هذا
همم هذا الذي حدث
بمقتل ااا نائب مدير شرطه محافظه معان
العقيد عبد الرزاق الدلابيح وقالوا انهم
يعني
يتبرؤون من اي مما يفعل ذلك وانهم يعني
ايضا في بيان محمد المسؤوليه الى الحكومه
التي فشلت برايهم في التعامل مع هذه
الازمه منذ 12 يوما
التي بدات باضرار السائقين همم سائقي
الشاحنات وسيارات العموميه والمتوسطه
والكبيره اا هذا يعني يؤثر على الازمه ما
زالت قائمه وان المواجهات مع الامن في
اكثر من منطقه كانت ليس فقط في مناطق
الجنوب سفيان يعني هنالك كان في ليله
الماضيه همم او في الساعات الماضيه كان
هناك ايضا تعامل الامن مع من حاول اغلاق
الطرق في الزرقاء كذلك من اشعل الاطارات
في عجلون شمالا وايضا في اتعشونا الجنوبيه
همم وكذلك في مادبا وفي ناعور يعني الحديث
عن عدد من المناطق التي شهدت مثل هذه
المواجهات والامن والدرك والقوات الدرك
كانت منتشره في كل هذه المناطق الا ان
يعني الحدث الابرز والاكبر كان في منطقه
الحسينيه همم اقرا مقتل العقيد التلابيح
وهو ضابط كبير في في الامن همم حتى اللحظه
الامن يطالب بعد عدم الانتفاض في كل من
يعني يحاول نشر المعلومات
الملصقه او غير الدقيقه كما قال والتي
تهدي الى تاجيل الشارع واطالبه الجميع
بهمم يعني التزام ابي بيانات الامن العام
التي تشير الى ما يحدث حسبما ورد في
البيان
المسؤوليه همم
وصلت الحديث عن مسؤوليه الحكومه كبير جدا
يبدو ان الحكومه وفقا لكثيرين من من
ينتقدوا اداءه خلال هذه الازمه قد قصرت في
التعامل مع حجم الازمه وتفاصيلها في تتعلق
بارتفاع اسعار المحروقات
هذا كان الطلب الوحيد والحكومه قدمت يعني
حلولا كانت بعيده عن هذا الطلب